gérald ya benjamin castaldi qui voudra
contrat pour l'année prochaine est ce
que tu lui dis oui
[Musique]
quel est votre rêve parce que lui son
rêve par exemple c'est d'aller à cannes
est ce que vous avez un rêve comme ça
que vous avons envie de faire sur les 48
prochaines heures
voilà vous savez les prochaines dates et
calmer sinon si vous pouvez marange est
d'autant plus comme ç'avait diffusion ce
but je préfèrerais à monaco la formule 1
monaco la formule 1 c'est fait non mais
c'est vrai on voulait déjà pas le tout
de suite le patron gérald brice viret
suite qu'ils appellent le grand patron
de canal+ jacques de mode à une équipe
de formule 1 ils m'ont dit impossible
monaco non il ya dix ares des
intellectuels et trois fois moins
j'appelle tout de suite j'appelle toute
financière serait le grand patron que le
relais nous dire vos rêves
je vais essayer dé réaliser gérald
wiimote chéri comment ça va je suis en
émission l'action en direct frérot dis
moi mon bébé bon gérald mathieu de leur
moi un rêve c'est d'assister au grand
prix de monaco je sais que c'est sur
c'est vite c'est le groupe canal est ce
que tu peux marc angers ça
merci mont gerald l'automne beinheim
quel est votre et brach mois mais il a
fait un truc et sympathique fait rien 3
passes et les passes un bond à la merci
évidemment continuer à travailler à vos
côtés autrement un abonnement canal est
possible j'ai eu deux abonnements
qu'elle a plus il voudrait qu'elle ait
pu sans racines se faire manger rate mon
chéri tu peux leur maître deux
abonnements canal wac sk n'a pu que cat
appel demain et tu peux leur faire au
moins fait laurent -50% fêter leurs 50 %
sur toute l'année c'est pour moi c'est
cadeau sachant qu'au travail alors on
voit jean michel maire et daniel melingo
s'occupe d'eux on aura la réponse demain
merci gerald je te dérange plus générale
c'est ce qu'on va faire on va mettre en
place un téléphone rouge
oui oui ce serait de faire aller retour
à las vegas et d'aller voir le spectacle
de david copperfield
on espère qu'on est sur le toit voir un
spectacle à las vegas jouer un petit peu
quelques jetons et puis ce fallait las
vegas ouais bon bah ça tu te démerdes
une liberté je voudrais bien mais fatwa
barcelone ce week-end ouais mais je suis
pas une agence de voyages et envois
castaldi qui comptera pour les
prochaines ça ne savent pas encore
j'appelle la jarrie
c'est bon vous l'a contraint ouais ouais
bon sens aurait voulu que maintenant oui
oui ça serait géré je le rappelle est
sympa j'appelle gérald ya benjamin
castaldi qui voudra contrat pour l'année
prochaine est ce que tu lui dis oui on a
bullet avec nous bonjour salut oui bruit
c est ce qu on peut rappeler monsieur
gérald pour réaliser mon rêve qui est
d'aller à cardiff pour la finale de la
ligue des champions
non mais ça c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon quant aux mondes occupation face et
vous le prenez sur vous la compréhension
de réaliser mon rêve
vous irez vous voulez qu'on appelle le
patron des sports de canal ah bah oui
c'est lui qui décide abbassi la poubelle
tout vérifier le maintien mais non mais
non j'ai dit oui parce que j'avais pas
envie de des plaques étaient encore
gerald p alors on tirait commencera mon
chéri tu as monaco alors tu sais que je
vais t'envoyer matthieu delormeau pour
le grand prix de monaco
ah oui c'est vrai dit moi vos thierry
moshiri je suis je suis à l'antenne
alors noté le patron des sports de canal
il me demande tous des rêves eya'a
gâteau proulx que tu connais qui
aimerait aller à la finale de la ligue
des champions à cardiff pour deux
personnes
elle est une personne de son choix est
ce que c'est possible ou pas mission
donc ces bâtisseurs s'attachant tout de
suite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci mon tir est entré en jeu rien
jean-luc alors pour les prochaines 48
heures je veux rien parce que je joue
mon spectacle à lille demain soir est
arrivé après demain mais j'ai comme un
rêve dites moi j'aimerais que mathieu
n'aille pas à monaco
[Applaudissements]
je rappellerai longtemps
je rappellerai toujours luc naret tibet
le pronom qui choisisse ou non mais non
c'est lui qui choisira aux couches mais
c'était de l'humour il a fait une rigole
pas c'est rené lescot luneray votre aide
je m'en fous je paye patrick schulmann
après et j'ai lu à m'organiser sahara
malien
attendez on rappelle géraldine giraud
j'appelle briser le déranger le train de
regarder la remise des césar
amer il me répond plus alors on va
essayer de réaliser votre à fait
d'accord
[Musique]